THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. SPONSORS OF THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT.
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HIS
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
WERE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
IN THE GALLERY TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALONE WILL BE USING
A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL JUST BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE. FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS FOUR SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX
EIGHT. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
OR THIS COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO.
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
UN MUTED. AND YOU WILL THEN BE
READY TO ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THIS HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WE HAVE A BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. THERE ARE TWO
BILLS PROPOSED FOR CONSENT FILE
ITEMS NUMBER FIVE. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY AND NUMBER EIGHT
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY ONE.
BEFORE WE HEAR THE PRESENTATION
ON THE BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BUT INSTEAD OF DIRECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO REMIND YOU TO PLEASE
SPEAK INTO YOUR MICROPHONE ROTH
YOUR ROTH HERE MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA HERE BEAT.
BEATS HERE BACKER. BACKER HERE
DADA EIGHT MEN. EIGHT MEN HERE
HER TADO. JONES I'M HERE JONES
HERE LEYVA MAN. MANY HERE NEWMAN
YOU MEAN HERE A SHOW ABOUT OKAY
YEAH A TURBO HERE PAN HERE HERE
AND HERE. WE HAVE A CORE OF.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOT TAKE UP OUR
CONSENT FILE. HE SAID HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR EGGMAN. THE
CONSENT FILE SENATE BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY BY MISTER JONES AND
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
BY MISTER ROTH. RALPH BY RALPH
HI MELINDA IS ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I'D BEAT RIGHT EIGHT
FIVE BACKERS ALL RIGHT BACKER HI
DONNA. ADMIN HI EIGHT MEN I HER
TADO JONES R. JONES II LLEVA.
MIN FIVE MIN I KNEW MAN ALL
RIGHT NEWMAN I I'D SHOW ABOUT
OKAY A SHOW ABOUT IPN HI CAN I.
YOUR TURN VOTES WILL HOLD ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. SIR
NEWMAN YOU HAVE ONE BILL TODAY
SENATE BILL TEN SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE PROCEED IN READING. THANK
YOU MICHIGAN MORNINGS MORE
MATURE AND MEMBERS I AM HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF SENATE BILL TEN SIXTY
FOUR- WHEN PASSES BETWEEN SIXTY
FOUR WILL ENSURE THAT ALL PEST
CONTROL WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ENJOY THE SAME SAFETY
PROTECTIONS AS OTHER LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS BY ADDING A NEW
SECTION. TO THE STRUCTURAL PEST
CONTROL ACT TO REQUIRE THAT AS A
CONDITION MAINTAINING A LICENSE
CALIFORNIA PEST CONTROL COMPANY
PROVIDE PROOF OF ACTIVITY
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE
UNDER CURRENT LAW PEST CONTROL
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO HOLD AN
ACTIVE INSURANCE POLICY THAT
GUARANTEES COVERAGE FOR UP TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR LOST. DUE TO INJURY OR
DESTRUCTION PROPERTY PEST
CONTROL COMPANIES HOWEVER ARE
NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO PROVE
THAT THEY STILL HAVE WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE THAT IS
VALID WHEN THEY APPLY TO RENEW A
LICENSE THE CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY CAN BE
DEVASTATING A FACT WHICH BECAME
CLEAR IN JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHAT A PEST CONTROL WORKER
PERFORMING A ROUTINE FUMIGATION
SERVICE IN ARCADIA. FELL TO HIS
DEATH FROM THE ROOF OF A TWO
STORY HOME A SUBSEQUENT
STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL BOARD
INVESTIGATION CONCLUDED THAT THE
PEST CONTROL COMPANY EMPLOYING
THE DECEASED WORKER HAD BEEN
OPERATING WITHOUT WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE IN
FEBRUARY OF THE PREVIOUS YEAR
THE FAMILY WOULD HAVE BEEN
ELIGIBLE FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE IF THE COMPANY HAD
THE REQUIRES WORK WORKERS
COMPENSATION COVERAGE. IN
ADDITION TO THE TRAGIC LOSS
BECAUSE OF THE ABSENCE OF
WORKERS COMP THE DECEASED
WORKERS FAMILY ENCOUNTER
SUBSTANTIAL FINANCIAL STRENGTH
UNDER SB TEN SIXTY FOUR THE
STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL BOARD
BOARD AS PART OF THE PROCESS FOR
ISSUING AND RENEWING LICENSES.
TO CALIFORNIA PEST CONTROL
COMPANIES THE BOARD WILL REQUIRE
VERIFICATION OF ACTIVE WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE UPON
RENEWAL AS WELL THIS BILL WILL
ALSO REQUIRE THE STATE
COMPENSATION INSURANCE FUND
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO NOTIFY
THE BOARD IN THE EVENT A
COMPANY'S POLICY HAS LAPSED
THEREBY ENSURING THAT ALL
LICENSED EMPLOYERS OF CALIFORNIA
PEST CONTROL WORKERS IT HERE TO
THIS. COMMONSENSE LONG NO
CALIFORNIA COMPANY WHO'S IN.
ENGAGED HIGH HAZARDOUS. SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO CIRCUMVENT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OBTAINING
REQUIRED COVERAGES AS P. TEN
SIXTY FOUR WILL ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERAL WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED. FROM FINANCIAL
LIABILITY ARISING FROM INJURY OR
DEATH ON THE JOB I BELIEVE I
HAVE MISTER CURTIS GOOD. THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL. BOARD
ON THE LINE WITH ME THIS
MORNING- BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR AN I. VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR OF. WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. LET ME
JUST SAY THAT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
CLEANING PROTOCOLS ETCETERA
COMMITTEE CHAIRS. ARE AUTHORIZED
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
IN THIS CASE WILL BE PERMITTED A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. MR COOK PLEASE MAKE MR
COOKS USING MISTER GOOD PLEASE
PROCEED.
SENATOR APPEARS THAT YOUR
WITNESS IS NOT ON THE LINE BUT
YOU DID GIVE A- ROUSING OPENING
IN. THANK YOU MR CHAIR WILL MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY-
HERE IN THE GALLERY ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY WISH TO
TESTIFY. THING NO WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY LET'S NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TEN SIXTY FOUR WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF TEN SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. THEY T. T. OPERATOR
WILL QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE AND THEN PLACE IT
BACK INTO THE QUEUE SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF TEN SIXTY
FOUR AND WE WILL BEGIN TODAY
MISTER CHAIRMAN LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN THE. I'M SORRY NO
COMMENT ON THE BILL. OKAY AND AS
A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. TEN
SIXTY FOUR. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE. FOR MANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION TO TEN
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT WE DO
HAVE ONE PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP. THIS ELKO AT EIGHT ONE ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SO AN
OPERATOR CAN GIVE YOU YOUR LIFE
NUMBER.
SHOULD BE WITH US ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
WE GO ARE THEY TOOK THEMSELVES
ARGUE I APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEMAND FOR
ON A DIFFERENT BILL IS THAT IT
IS MODERATOR. AND I DID IT THIS
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU LET'S
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. CENTERING
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD MAKING
SURE. WHO ARE DOING PEST CONTROL
HAVE ALL OF THE THINGS THEY NEED
IN PLACE TO DO THAT. AND I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU SIR
EDMUND CENTER ARCHULETA. YES I'D
LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE THE
BILL BUT BEFORE I. A COMMENT- ON
THAT I'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
EMPHASIZE HOW IMPORTANT THIS
BILL IS. IN HOW THOSE IN THE
REAL ESTATE INDUSTRY I HAVE A- A
AN ENTIRE BASKET OF SERVICE. TO
THE CLIENTELE AND ONE WOULD BE
IN- THE TERMITE INDUSTRY AND
THAT TITLE COMPANIES AND JUST. A
WHOLE SLEW OF INDIVIDUALS. AND
NOW THAT I THINK THAT- WE CAN
ALL BE COMFORTABLE THAT EVERY
EMPLOYEE WHO STEPPED FOOT. ON A
HOUSE IN A HOUSE RATHER- WILL BE
COVERED. THE EMPLOYEES AND WHAT
A RELIEF. TO THE HOMEOWNER. AND
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU SEARCH LETTER COLLEAGUES ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS I SEE NO OTHER MIKES UP
. SENATOR NEWMAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I THANK YOU MR THANK
YOU TO BOTH OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR COMMENTS THIS BILL IS
COMPLETELY IN KEEPING WITH THE
MODEL OF THIS BODY SENATE TAURUS
S. CIVITATIS LIBERTAD HIM TO
WORRY AND WITH THAT. I RESPECT
THAT YOU'RE NOT ABLE. THANK YOU
SIR WE HAVE A MOTION CENTER
ADMIN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT MADAM STAFF DIRECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATE
BILL TEN SIXTY FOUR DO YOU PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT RALPH HI RALPH HI
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I'D BE. BEATS I BACKER ALL RIGHT
BACKER I DON. EIGHT MEN HI EIGHT
MEN I HER TADO JONES. JONES I
LEAVE A MAN HI MAY NINE NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I HAVE A BOGUS. UNTIL
ABOUT FIVE PM HI CAN I. LET'S
TURN VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU SIR. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
SKINNER. WITH SENATE BILL. TEN
SEVENTY FIVE CENTER SKINNER
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
MEMBERS S. B. TEN SEVENTY FIVE
WILL ENABLE US TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
THIS THE INTENT OF SOME FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT IS NOW AVAILABLE TO
ESTABLISH HYDROGEN HOPES
HYDROGEN SPECIFICALLY GREEN
HYDROGEN IS POISED TO HELP
CALIFORNIA IN THE WORLD
DECARBONISE OUR ECONOMY AND IS
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE INNOVATIONS IN
SO MANY OF THE DECARBONISATION
TECHNOLOGIES WHETHER IT'S SOLAR
WIND ENERGY STORAGE BATTERY
UTILIZING BATTERIES AND OTHERS.
WE WANT TO BE IN THE SAME
POSITION REGARDING HYDROGEN.
HYDROGEN CAN BE MADE FROM
ELECTRICITY THAT WAS GENERATED
FROM RENEWABLE SOURCES SUCH AS
OLAR AND WIND. IT CAN
DECARBONISE DIFFICULT SECTORS
LIKE SHIPPING FREIGHT VEHICLES
AIR TRAVEL DIFFERENT
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRIES IT ALSO
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE A GREAT
FORM OF STORAGE FOR ELECTRICITY.
AND BECAUSE HE CAN UTILIZE MUCH
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE IT CAN
PRESERVE WELL PAYING JOBS THE
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
INCLUDED ABOUT TEN BILLION IN
HYDROGEN INVESTMENTS IN UP TO
TWO BILLION EACH FOR REGIONAL
HYDROGEN HUBS. THIRTY SP TEN
SEVENTY FIVE ADVANCES GREEN
HYDROGEN BY ESTABLISHING A GREEN
HYDROGEN HUB FUND TO PROVIDE
STATE MATCHING WHICH WOULD BE
REQUIRED FOR US TO BE
COMPETITIVE IN ORDER TO GET
ACCESS FEDERAL MONIES. AND IT
ALSO DIRECTS STATE AGENCIES TO
ADOPT GREEN HARD TO CHANGE INTO
THEIR DECARBONIZATION PLANNING
EFFORTS SO REQUIRES R. AGIR
RESOURCES BOARD FOR EXAMPLE TO
DEVELOP A ROAD MAP FOR HYDROGEN
ROLL OUT IN CALIFORNIA. AND
REQUIRES OR VARIOUS OTHER
AGENCIES TO ESTABLISH SOME
DEFINITIONS FOR CLEANER GREEN
HYDROGEN THERE IS A DEFINITION
IN THIS BILL BUT IT IS THE
DEFINITION OF- THAT THE FED
GOVERNMENT IS USING AND THE
DEFINITION IN THIS BILL IS ONLY
RELATES TO THE HUB. AND IT
STATED PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AND TO
ENABLE US TO BE COMPETITIVE FOR
THAT FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS TO
ENABLE TO US TO ALIGN HOPEFULLY
GET SOME OF THAT MONEY. SO I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MY EXPERTS
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY I'VE GOT
JANICE LYNN FROM THE GREEN
HYDROGEN COALITION AND MATT
DAVIS FROM THE PORT OF OAKLAND.
THANK YOU SENATOR WITNESSES
PLEASE PROCEED. HI MY NAME IS
JANET PLAN AND I'M THE FOUNDER
AND PRESIDENT OF THE GREEN
HYDROGEN COLLECTION FOR FIVE OH
ONE SEE THREE HIS MISSION IS TO
ACCELERATE GREEN AND ASKING L.
THIS IS PHYLLIS HATE MULTI
SECTORAL DECARBONISATION AND
CLEAN AND JUST ENERGY TRANSITION
I'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
SKINNER FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING OUR CLIMATE CRISIS.
AND FOR CONSIDERING THE GOLD
ROLLING GREEN HYDROGEN IN
ACHIEVING THE URGENT CALL IN
ADDITION TO FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE THE WAR IN UKRAINE AND
RESULTING VOLATILITY AND TALK
WITH YOUR CONTENT INCREASING
URGENCY FOR ALEX. BLURRING
SCALABLE ALTERNATIVE. GREEN
HYDROGEN COMMERCIAL VIABLE. AND
SCALABLE. TO FOSSIL FUELS
TUESDAY ADDRESSING EVEN THE
HARDEST OF THE FACTORS SUCH AS
HEAVY DUTY TRANSPORT SHIPPING
AND AVIATION. HOWEVER TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEIR VERY LARGE
EMERGING GLOBAL ECONOMY
CALIFORNIA MUST ACT NOW. GREEN
HYDROGEN IS THE NEW OIL OF OUR
GENERATION BUT UNLIKELY ALL
GREEN HYDROGEN PRODUCED FROM
RENEWABLE RESOURCES THIS MEANS
THAT IT'S A GREAT HANDS AGAIN I
HOPE YOU'LL PRICE VOLATILITY.
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD ARE
GEARING UP. TO BECOME A LOW COST
PRODUCER. SCHEELE S. HELLO SORRY
THE OTHER EXAMPLES FORTY IF YOU
CAN TO JAPAN AND CHILE AND SAUDI
ARABIA HAVE ANNOUNCED THEIR
INTENT TO COMPETE WITH AUSTRALIA
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE AMONG THE
INTERNATIONAL PERSONAL CARS WERE
BLESSED WITH AN ABUNDANCE OF
PEACOCK PRODUCED VERY LOW COST
CLEAN HYDROGEN AT THE END OF THE
MENTIONED BILL. IS RESPECTFUL OF
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR RESOURCES
WIND SOLAR ORGANIC PATHWAYS TO
BAN IT RECOGNIZES THAT WE HAVE
MANY HIGH VOLUME APPLICATION
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA FROM
WHICH TO SCALE INCLUDING
MANAGING AND FUELING NORTH
AMERICA'S LARGEST PORTS AIRPORTS
AND. INDUSTRIAL AGRICULTURAL
SECTORS. B. TEN SEVEN FIVE RIGHT
THAT CREATE OF THE GREEN BECAUSE
THEN WE WILL NOT ONLY HELP US
ACHIEVE OUR ECONOMY WIDE
ACCREDITATION GOALS BUT IT WILL
ALSO PLACE CALIFORNIA AMONG A
GROWING GROUP OF LEADING NATIONS
WILL ULTIMATELY HELP. SATISFY
INTERNATIONAL DEMANDS. THE GREEN
HYGIENIC OUT SYSTEM INCLUDES
SCALE PRODUCTION TRANSPORT
STORAGE AND DOWNSTREAM
APPLICATION INFRASTRUCTURE ALL
ALONG THE VALUE CHAIN IS
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTRACT BILLIONS OF INVESTMENT
DOLLARS CREATE THOUSANDS OF
SKILLED FAMILY SUSTAINING JOBS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
PARTICULARLY LOCATIONS IN THE
STATE WHERE COMMUNITIES.
SUFFERED. THE MOST FROM THE
IMPACTS OF POPULAR. SENATOR
MENTIONED WE'RE TO RE MY AS
THREE BILLION. EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL CLEAN AND
GREEN HYDROGEN HUB FUNDING. IN
ADDITION TO SETTING FORTH A
VISION FOR WHAT THE POSSIBLE
BECAUSE SEVENTY FIVE CREATE A
TIMELY VEHICLE FOR ENSURING THAT
OUR APPLICATIONS ARE COMPETITIVE
AND WE ATTRACTED MUCH FEDERAL
FUNDING IF POSSIBLE. BE
SENTIMENTALLY FIVE AND CENTRAL
TO ACHIEVING OUR ECONOMY WIDE
CARBON EMISSION GOALS AND
SETTING UP CALIFORNIA THE
NATIONAL AND ULTIMATELY GLOBAL
LEADER IN GREEN HYDROGEN FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EITHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS MISS LAN MISTER MISTER
DAVIS ANY BRIEF COMMENTS TO ADD. YES THANK YOU CHAIRMAN I WILL
BE BRIEF ON BEHALF OF THE PORT
OF OAKLAND IS- IT OFFERS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL WE HAD A
LONG DECADE LONG EFFORT TO
ADVANCE AND SUPPORT OUR CLEAN
AIR QUALITY PROGRAMS AND AS WE
TRY TO MOVE INTO A COMPLETE
DECARBONISATION STRATEGY
HYDROGEN POWER AND FREE HYDROGEN
POWER SPECIFICALLY ARE GOING TO
BE KEY COMPONENTS AND SHOOTING
THESE CALLS. WERE STANDING UP A
NUMBER OF DEMONSTRATION PROGRAMS
WHICH UTILIZE FUEL CELL HI I'M
CLASS EIGHT HYDROGEN TRUCKS AND-
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TWO ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTNER WITH
OUR STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SO THAT WE CAN I RESPECTFULLY
ASHLEY I LOVE. THANKS ANDERSON.
THANK SIR LET'S NOW HERE ANYONE
. AND GALLERY. WHAT IN THE
GALLERY ON THIS BILL SIR PLEASE-
IDENTIFY YOURSELF PLEASE AND WE
REPRESENT. THE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL WHAT WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
SAY THAT AGAIN WE DIDN'T CATCH
YOU WITH THE MIKE ALL RIGHT MIKE
MADIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AS WELL AS THE COALITION
FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO COME DOWN
AND COME AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY YOU WISH TO MAKE
COMMENTS ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL
. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA%
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES.
WAITED FIRST FIND SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY FIVE WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU FOR SURE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BILL S.
S. B. AT TEN SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
FLYING SIXTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER AND
TURNER IS LIVING IN A CAR LOT.
ON BEHALF OF UNIVERSAL HYDROGEN
BEFORE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
OPEN- GOOD MORNING SIXTY WALL
COMING UP THE CENTER OF
PROCRASTINATION BARMAN IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR MODERATOR
NEXT PLEASE. WHY TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING X.
SHARE MEMBERS THAT FOLLOW THEM
WITH THE WIDENING GROUP ON
BEHALF OF BLOOM ENERGY HI DIRECT
AND STRONG THE CAR AND AT THE
TIME RIGHT YEAH THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU WE WILL
GO TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR BRADY
BORDERING WITH FUEL CELL ENERGY
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANKS
PLEASE AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO THE POPE-
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE ONE TWENTY THREE
YOUR OPEN- TURNER WITH NILA
PATTERSON ASSOCIATES. SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THEM HE- THANK YOU SIR
NEXT PLEASE. THE OVERLYING
SEVENTEEN YOUR OPEN. HI THIS IS
ALEX MORRIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY STORAGE ALLIANCE WE'RE
EXCITED THE PROGRESS I DIDN'T
THINK THAT WAS A SMART MOVE FOR
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM- IT'S JUST
ANOTHER TYPE OF STORAGE TO US
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE IT IN PLAY
SO WE SUPPORT AT. TEN SEVENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU SIR MODERATOR
NEXT PLEASE. AND WE HAVE A
TRUSTED SECURITY CARE. THANK YOU
LET'S- FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. TEN SEVENTY FIVE. ON
THE PHONE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TSTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. MR SURE NOBODY
IS KILLING UP. OKAY LET'S SIR
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
CHAMBER AND MY COLLEAGUES-
FIRST- SENATOR MAN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR NEWMAN AND SENATOR
EGGMAN AND SENATOR ARCHULETA
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN- I WANT TO
APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY FOR THIS BILL- I HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING UC
IRVINE AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO COME CHECK IT OUT-
THEY'VE GOT THEY'RE DOING SOME
REALLY AMAZING THINGS ON
HYDROGEN- I WHEN I LAST VISITED
THEM LAST YEAR I DID MENTION TO
ME THAT THEY HAD GOTTEN A 92%
EFFICIENCY. AS FAR AS HYDROGEN
STORAGE AND I THINK THE
POTENTIAL FOR THIS TECHNOLOGY
ARE REALLY EXCITING- YES AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW I SUPPORT A
TECHNOLOGY AGNOSTIC APPROACH TO
TRYING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH I DO
BELIEVE IS THAT THE BIGGEST
CRISIS WE'RE FACING IS THAT AS A
SPECIES AND SO WE'RE GONNA GET
THIS RIGHT IF WE'RE GONNA SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM BUT WE DO NEED TO
EXPLORE OPTIONS AND GIVEN HOW
EXCITING HYDROGEN IS- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PUT OUR
MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS AND I
INVEST THE RESOURCES IN IN THIS
TYPE OF RESEARCH SO- I WOULD ASK
THE MINI COOPER AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND AGAIN THANK
YOU. SENATOR SKINNER FOR THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
DIED CHER MY COLLEAGUES
INCLUSION FOR HYGIENIST SOME OF
YOU MAY KNOW I AM THE SELF
APPOINTED CHAIR OF THE HYGIENE
KERR CAUCUS IN THE LEGISLATURE-
AND THIS IS TRULY. A
TRANSFORMATIVE TECHNOLOGY BUT
THIS IS ALSO A CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA I
COMMEND MY COLLEAGUES TO BRING
THIS BILL FOR- PLEASE ALLOWS US
TO MAKE THE BEST USE OF A
FEDERAL OPPORTUNITY AND IN SO
DOING- BUILD AN EXCITING FUTURE
FOR HYDROGEN DECARBONISATION
CALIFORNIA I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR WHEN
THAT'S APPROPRIATE I AND TO MOVE
THE BILL- WHEN THE TIME COMES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR AND
SENATOR EDMUND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I GUESS WE'RE ALL JUST AT A
COURSE HERE- LIKING SENATOR
SKINNER'S BILL AND I HAVE BEEN
PROUD TO CO AUTHOR OF SOME OF
THOSE BILLS THAT SHE WORKED ON
IN THE PAST AND WOULD LIKE TO DO
SO AGAIN IF I HAVEN'T ALREADY
BUT I JUST THINK IT'S VERY
EXCITING WHEN THERE'S A
TECHNOLOGY THAT COMES ALONG- NOT
JUST COMES ON BUT THAT IS THAT
IS GREEN THAT CAN ACTUALLY MOVES
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS. AND
BUILDS ON- THE VERY PRAGMATIC
ISSUES WE HAVE A ROW WASTE BOTH
WITH AND WHERE WE DIE JESTERS
AND WITH BIOMASS AND THEN
ACTUALLY TURNING INTO THAT INTO
A GREEN A FEW- I JUST THINK IT'S
A VERY EXCITING ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO MY DISTRICT AND THE
AMOUNT OF TRUCKS DRIVING UP AND
DOWN THE FREEWAY AND REALLY
ADMITTING SOME VERY HARMFUL
THINGS. FOR THE HEALTH OF THE
VALLEY SO I WOULD
ENTHUSIASTICALLY MOVED HIS BILL
IS IT HASN'T BEEN MOVED BEFORE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
CENTER ARCHULETA THANK YOU MR
HERE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HYDROGEN ENERGY
I'M EXCITED ABOUT SENATE BILL
TEN SEVENTY FIVE IN A APPLY MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR SKINNER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD TO
SEEK THE FUNDING THAT WE NEED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO REQUEST
THAT CALIFORNIA LEAD THE WAY IS
SO VERY IMPORTANT- HYDROGEN
BEING THAT PART OF THE TREASURE
CHEST OF ENERGY. AND I THINK NOW
ALL OF US REALIZE THAT THIS DAY
AND AGE WE HAVE TO FIND EVERY
TECHNOLOGY WE COULD FIND CLEANER
AIR AND FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
OUR HUMAN BEINGS WE'VE GOT TO
CLEAN UP OUR AIR AND WHAT BETTER
WAY TO START WITH- FUEL CELL
HYDROGEN AND HYDROGEN IN GENERAL
JOBS JOBS JOBS TO BE CREATED
THAT'S ANOTHER FACET AND I- I
JUST- CAN'T TO. GET ANY MORE
EXCITED THAN THAT I'M TELLING
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I TOO
WOULD LIKE TO BE. A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU MR. THANK YOU SENATOR
HATCH KELLY ANY FOR QUESTIONS
COME CAN. I SEE NO MIKE'S UP.
HELLO CENTER SCANNER WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
FAIR- FIVE EIGHT THIS WAS
REFERRED THIS WAS ALLUDED TO BUT
I DIDN'T EXPLICITLY STATED WHICH
IS THAT THE OTHER ANOTHER GREAT
ADVANTAGE OF HYDROGEN IF WE CAN
DO IT. IN A WAY THAT IS ACTUALLY
LOW CARBON IS THAT IT CAN ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE AIR
POLLUTANTS THAT CAUSE SMOG
BECAUSE IT HAS THE BENEFIT TO BE
APPLIED TO THINGS LIKE GOODS
MOVEMENT IN OUR PORTS WHICH ARE
SOME OF OUR LARGEST SOURCES. OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE DIRTYING THE
AIR IN THOSE COMMUNITIES SO IT
SAYS IT'S ONE OF THOSE TOOLS
THAT- LIKE OUR SENATOR FROM
IRVINE ORANGE COUNTY REFERENCED.
IN I'M I LIKE TO BE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL HOWEVER I THINK WE WANT
TO BE POSITIONED AND THIS WOULD
HELP US POSITION BECAUSE THERE'S
ALL THE ADVANCEMENTS AROUND
HYDROGEN ARE HAPPENING FAST AND
FURIOUS AND WE WANT TO BE RIGHT
THERE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
AND WITH THAT- I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
WE HAVE A MOTION ON SENATE BILL
TEN SEVENTY FIVE MOVED BY
SENATOR NEWMAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AS HE TURNED SEVENTY FIVE D.
PASSANT RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS ROTH TIME
ROSS I MELINDA'S ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D BEAT. EIGHT FIVE.
DAUGHTER EIGHT MEN BY ADMIN I
HER TADO JONES JONES I. LEIVA
MEN. MAN MAN MAN I KNEW MAN ALL
RIGHT NEWMAN I A SHOW ABOUT OPEN
UNTIL ABOUT- GUY HAN HI CAN I.
BILL HAS NINE VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELCOME CENTER BECAUSE ALL YOU
HAVE TO BUILD ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY SENATE BILL ELEVEN ZERO
FOUR AND SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE WE'LL START WITH
SENATE BILL. ELEVEN ZERO FOUR.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD MORNING-
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT US B.
ELEVEN OH FOUR WHICH WILL DANCE
THE COORDINATION ECONOMIC
VITALITY OF OUR FREIGHT SECTOR.
OF THE FREIGHT SECTOR DRIVES ONE
THIRD OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
CREATING MILLIONS OF JOBS AS WE
KNOW IN MOVING TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF GOODS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. HOWEVER DESPITE THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF THE
FREIGHT SECTOR THE RECENT SUPPLY
CHAIN CRISIS IS MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THIS COMPLEX SYSTEM IS
BETTER HIGH LEVEL COORDINATION
IN PLANNING S. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR
ACTUALLY ADDRESSES THAT. BY
CREATING AN OFFICE OF FREIGHT
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND REQUIRING THIS
OFFICE TO DEVELOP AN ASSESSMENT
PLAN- FOR THE ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVENESS OF THE SECTOR.
THE OFFICE OF FREE WILL ALSO ACT
AS THE STATE ENTITY THAT WILL
FACILITATE COORDINATION FOR THE
MANY STAKEHOLDERS ALONG THE
SUPPLY CHAIN- AND A GLARING
EXAMPLE OF THE LOSSES CALIFORNIA
INCURRED BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
FREE. ECONOMIC PLANNING IS THAT
WE'RE MISSING OUT ON FEDERAL
DOLLARS AS WELL WEST COAST PORTS
HAVE RECIEVED ONLY ABOUT 10% OF
FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE HISTORICALLY WHEN
COMPARED TO THE DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO EASTERN GULF COAST.
S. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR WILL
ADDRESS THESE SHORTCOMINGS AND
ENABLE BETTER STATEWIDE ECONOMIC
PLANNING AND COORDINATION
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TODAY IN PERSON I BELIEVE I
HAVE MARTHA MILLER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PORT AUTHORITIES AND
MIKE JACOBS FROM THE PACIFIC
MARITIME. I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME
THE CIVIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION I DO NOT HAVE MY
GLASSES ON THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
SB ELEVEN OH FOUR. THANK YOU MR
THANK YOU SENATOR MISS MILLER MS
JACOB PLEASE PROCEED. MIKE
PLEASE. HANG ON. WE'LL GET YOUR
MIKE. THAT'S RIGHT NOW OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN-
BROUGHT MEMBERS MIKE JACOB WITH-
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN OH FOUR. AND BANKS
INTERNEES ALL FOR THE
INTRODUCTION. OF WE DO HAVE A
VERY SERIOUS- ISSUE AS YOU ALL
KNOW WITH RESPECT TO SUPPLY
CHAIN CRISIS. AND OUR ONGOING
IMPACTS FROM COVE IN PANDEMIC
AND RESULTING- IMPACTS TO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE- REALLY SORELY
MISSED- AND THE RESPONSES SUPPLY
CHAIN IS DIRECT COORDINATION
ACROSS ALL OF OUR AGENCIES. AS
AN INSTITUTIONAL MATTER AT THIS
STAGE. VISIBILITY DRESSES THAT.
IT FACILITATES COORDINATION IN
INSTITUTIONAL WAY BY MAKING THAT
THE RESPONSIBILITY. OF GO B. AS
AN OFFICE OF FREIGHT IS
ESTABLISHED. WE SUPPORT THAT. WE
ASK FOR THAT AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION FOR
THIS BILL. IN ADDITION THE BILL
DOES FOSTER A LONG TERM PLACE
FOR THE STATE TO ADDRESS
COMPETITIVENESS. WHICH AS YOU
ALL KNOW IS- A LONG TERM ISSUE
FACING OUR SUPPLY CHAIN AND
REPORTS AS WE- TRY OUR BEST TO
MAINTAIN. OUR CARGO IN THE FACE
COMPETITION FROM OTHER STATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND IN CANADA
AND MEXICO. SO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU SIR MS MILLER. HELLO
MY NAME IS MARTHA MILLER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PORT
AUTHORITIES WHICH CONSISTS OF
THE ELEVEN COMMERCIAL SEAPORTS
IN CALIFORNIA- AND WE'RE HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN OH FOUR BY SENATOR LENA
GONZALES. AND DESPITE THE
TO CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE AND
ECONOMY THE RECENT SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS IS SHOWING THE CONFERENCE
RATE SECTOR IS IN NEED OF BETTER
PLANNING AND COORDINATION ACROSS
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. IN RESPONSE
TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS THE
BY THE MINISTRATION RECOGNIZING
THE NEED FOR CENTRALIZED
LEADERSHIP APPOINTED A POOR
ENVOY TO MEET ACROSS SECTORS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
NATIONAL SUPPLY CHAIN. TO
MITIGATE THE CONGESTION IN REAL
TIME WE SAW THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS FEDERAL APPROACH. AND WHILE
GO BIZ AND HOUSE TO HAVE TAKEN
LEADERSHIP ROLES IN FACILITATING
COORDINATION THERE'S CURRENTLY
NO STATE ENTITY OFFICE OR
POSITION WITH THE AUTHORITY AND
CAPACITY TO COORDINATE ACROSS
THE ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
SUPPORTING AGENCIES. CAPA ALONG
WITH OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE GOODS MOVEMENT SECTOR
INCLUDING GO BANDS CAL STAR. THE
CDFA- PARTICIPATED IN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPLY CHAIN SUCCESS
SUMMIT THIS PAST FALL I KEEP
FINDING FROM THE SUMMIT WHICH
AIMS TO ADDRESS THE COMPLEX
CHALLENGES FACING OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN WAS THAT OUR STATE MUST
DEVELOP A CENTRALIZED STATE
OFFICE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IDENTIFYING. AND SETTING CLEAR
GOALS THAT PROMOTE ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVENESS IN THE FREIGHT
SECTOR HAS TO BE ELEVEN OH FOUR
WILL DIRECTLY ADDRESS THIS
RECOMMENDATION BY ESTABLISHING
THE OFFICE OF FREIGHT THE
SERVICE THE COORDINATING ENTITY
TO STEER COMPETITIVENESS AND
SUSTAINABILITY. ACROSS EVERY
SECTOR AS WE LOOK TO THE FUTURE
AND CONTINUE TO WORK ON
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL HELP GET
KIDS MOVING FASTER WE BELIEVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SMARTER
COORDINATION WITHIN STATE
LEADERSHIP IS CRITICAL. THANK
YOU AGAIN AND WE APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR GONZALES.
THANK YOU MA'AM. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. USING THE
WITNESS. WILL NOW MOVE TO.
WISHING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL ELEVEN ZERO FOUR WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK YOU
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO PUT THE
SUPPORT OF A ONE ONE ZERO FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN OH FOUR. AND
MR JOURNAL BUT HE IS HEALING UP
. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS LET'S NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM ANY OPPOSITION JUST
CHECKING IN AGAIN IN THE GALLERY
ANY WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THING
NONE LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THE SENATE
BILL ELEVEN ZERO FOUR WE WILL
CONTINUE. EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR
ELEVEN OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. OKAY LET'S BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO-
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER. ALL
THESE QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS STARTING WITH SENATOR
PAN ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
THANK GOD THAT THE CONTROLS
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- I ALSO REPRESENT
THE PORT'S NOT AS LARGE AS YOURS
BY FAR- DEPORTED SACRAMENTO- IN
WEST SACRAMENTO- IN TERMS OF
THE- YOUR BILL- HE MAYBE SPEAK
TO I MEAN. PART OF THE YOU KNOW
THE SECTORS MOST OF THE SPONSORS
ARE RELATED REPORTS WE HAVE AN
ANALYSIS WE TALK ABOUT TRUCKING
BUT HE TALKED ABOUT THE ROLE OF
RAIL IN THE FREE PLAN AND IS AND
HOW HOW DOES THAT FIT INTO YOUR
BILL. ABSOLUTELY YOU OUT TO THE
CHAIR- MR SURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR PAN- AND- THIS IS
THE ISSUE NOW IS THAT IT'S
PRETTY FRAGMENTED SO CAL STUFF.
I'M CURRENTLY HAS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING AND SO
WE DO HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
FREIGHT MOBILITY PLAN- THIS-
ASKS FOR AN ADDITIONAL PLANETS
OVER ARCHES BETWEEN THE- HEALTH%
STUFF- AND THEN COOK GO BIZ
WHICH HAS. ONE POSITION THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING TO FILL THAT'S
ACTUALLY VACANT RIGHT NOW BUT
THAT LOOKS AT ECONOMIC VITALITY
BUT IT'S- IT'S FRAGMENTED SO
WE'RE HOPING TO BRING THEM ALL
TOGETHER THROUGH THIS OFFICE OF
RATE. THAT WILL INCLUDE A
ANOTHER UPDATE ON THE MOBILITY
PLAN AND OF COURSE INCLUDES A
RAIL AS WELL BUT IF MY WITNESSES
HAVEN'T ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. YOU
THAT. IF WE'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
THEM AS WELL. PLEASE PROCEED.
THEY'RE BETTER L. R. A. I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER WITNESSES WANT TO
STAY AT ANYTHING BUT- I DON'T
KNOW IF EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
MILLER MISTER JACOB HAS ANY
ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS. THIRTY YOU
HAVE ANY. FURTHER COMMENTS WITH
REGARD TO CENTER PANTS
QUESTIONER. THANK YOU SENATOR
VAN- IT IT'S A IT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION AS THE MOUSE'S POINTS
OUT THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
TOUCH POINTS FOR FREIGHT AND
THAT'S PRIMARILY THE PURPOSE FOR
THIS BILL NOW WITH RESPECT TO
RAIL IN PARTICULAR RAIL IS
COVERED THROUGH THE FREE
MOBILITY PLAN HAS ITS OWN STATE
RAIL PLAN. IT'S A SEPARATE
COMPONENT OF THE GOODS EMISSION
REDUCTION PLAN FROM THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD- AND MANY OTHER
TOUCH POINTS THE SENATORS ALSO
ADDED TO THIS IS- OUR HOPE FOR
THIS PROCESS THAT THE OFFICE OF
FREIGHT WITH AND- PROVIDE AN
OVERARCHING PLACE FOR HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT COORDINATING
THOSE POLICIES. RIGHT WHAT WHAT
I'D APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER I
THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE INTEGRATE ALL THE DIFFERENT
MODES OF TRANSPORTATION AS WE
MOVE FREIGHT- WHETHER IT'S AT
TWO PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA OR
THROUGH CALIFORNIA- OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY. AND SO WITH THAT
I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE TO BUILD
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR PENN CENTER ARCH ALETTA
. YES THANK YOU THIS YEAR. I'D
LIKE TO COMMENT THAT- MY
DISTRICT THE THIRTY SECOND RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY
FREEWAYS COMING OUT OF LOS
ANGELES AND IN SAN PEDRO IN THE
POOR AREAS- HAD BEEN THE STRONG
BACKING OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THIS IS ONE ELEMENT THAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL I
THINK IT'LL REALLY KICKSTART
THINGS AND MOVE THINGS ALONG
BECAUSE WE HAVE LOST THEIR
CALIFORNIA BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BECAUSE OF THE- HOLD UP THERE AT
THE PORCH AND WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S INVOLVEMENT. AND I
THINK THAT THIS WILL REALLY MOVE
THINGS FORWARD AND I- APPRECIATE
THE SENATORS- BRINGING FORWARD
THIS BILL ELEVEN OH FOUR NINE
WOULD APPRECIATE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR COLLINS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NO MIKE'S. THOSE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MR
CHAIR- AS IT STANDS NOW KERR HAS
A FEW HUNDRED POSITIONS OF
FOCUSED ON FREIGHT MOBILITY AT
CAL STAR HAS. IS IT REQUESTING-
A COUPLE POSITIONS IN THIS
YEAR'S PROPOSED BUDGET AGO
BUSINESS CURRENTLY HAS A VACANCY
SO- WITH ONE PORT THAT I HAVE
PORT OF LONG BEACH EMPLOYS OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
WITH A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS.
OF REVENUE COMING IN IT'S
DEFINITELY NEEDED SO WITH THAT I
SET A CERTAINLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE I THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THE QUESTIONS ON THE LEFT S. B.
ELEVEN OH FOUR. THANK YOU SIR
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
AN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION. MADAM STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND IT BILL ELEVEN OH FOUR G.
PASSING RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION ROTH
. AUTHOR HI MELINDA'S ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D BE EIGHT FIVE
BACKER. DOT I DON HI A MAN A MAN
I HER TADO JONES HI JONES II
LLEVA. HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN I I'D
SHOW BOGUE AND SHOW VOGUE IPN HI
CAN I LIST TEN VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
. SURE YOU HAVE YOUR SECOND BILL
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE PROCEED IN READING THANK
YOU AGAIN MR TURN MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SP THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE WHICH WILL HELP
FOSTER GREATER EQUITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S TECHNOLOGY AND
START UP BUSINESSES- WHILE
DIRECTING DIRECTLY SUPPORTING
THE STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S WE KNOW IS THE TECH
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD IS HOME TO
COUNTLESS POWERHOUSE COMPANIES
THAT SUPPORT MILLIONS OF JOBS
DESPITE OUR STATE LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA THERE ARE THERE
CERTAINLY REMAINS A SERIOUS GAP
IN OPPORTUNITIES. FOR FUNDING
FOR LGBTQ COMMUNITY MEMBERS
MINORITY AND WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS
ESPECIALLY AS MANY WOMEN- WE
KNOW THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC OUR
UNEMPLOYED AND THEY TURNED TO
ENTREPRENEURSHIP DATA SHOWS THAT
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS RATES
FOR BLACK AND LATINO FOUNDER
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN REPRESENTS
ONLY A MERE TWO POINT 4% OF THE
TOTAL U. S. VENTURE CAPITAL
RAISED DURING THAT TIME. THE
NUMBERS ARE MORE STARK FOR BLACK
FEMALE ENTREPRENEURS RECEIVED
JUST POINT 34% A VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING WE KNOW THE SAME AS
OTHER IS THIS IT WE KNOW THE
SAME MORE OF THE SAME FOR OTHER
MINORITY GROUPS LIKE THE API
COMMUNITY AND SUCH. S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE WILL HELP
TACKLE THE INEQUITY FROM THE
GROUND UP BY FUNDING THE
INNOVATIVE IN SPIN FOR STRUCTURE
NEEDED BY NEW AND DEVELOPING
COMPANIES AND PROMOTING THE
CREATION OF A LOCALIZED SUPPORT
ECOSYSTEM SPECIFICALLY THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE CREATES THE
CALIFORNIA TECH WITTY INNOVATION
FUND UNDER GO BIZ. THE FUND WILL
BE USED TO OPEN DOORS OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE VERY
BUSINESSES AND WILL SUPPORT
LOCAL ACCELERATORS INCUBATORS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS THAT HELP
PREPARE THESE NASCENT BUSINESSES
TO GET OFF THE GROUND.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY OF
THIS MEASURE IS ANDREA WHITE
BECAUSE AUSTIN MANAGING DIRECTOR
FOR THE LONG BEACH ACCELERATOR
AND TYLER BUT NOT- CURLY WITH
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH THANK YOU
I RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I BOUGHT
ON THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU SENATOR. WITNESSES YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS TYLER BANANA
CURLY I'M THE MANAGER OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH. LONG BEACH IS THE
LEADER IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND WE BELIEVE SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE WILL ADVANCE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EQUITY TECH
START UP. STATE WIDE. THE TYPE
OF PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
WE'VE ESTABLISHED IN LONG BEACH.
THE PRESERVATION OF THE NEXT
PHASE IN DIGITAL INCLUSION. THE
STATE HAS INVESTED SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY. GIVE BACK THE NECK
WHICH REMAIN IN TECH
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
UNDERREPRESENTED START UPS ARE
OFTEN UNABLE TO ACCESS VENTURE
CAPITAL FUNDING WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT. TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND TRAINING OFFERED BY
NONPROFIT INCUBATORS AND
ACCELERATORS. HOWEVER WITHOUT
PUBLIC INVESTMENT TO BUILD THESE
ECOSYSTEMS NONPROFITS STRUGGLE
TO GET THE OPERATIONAL RESOURCES
FACILITY FAITH AND SAFFING
NECESSARY TO DELIVER SERVICES
AND EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING
CHECK WITH THE TECH
ENTREPRENEURS. EARS PROPOSED
STATE BUDGET WOULD HELP ADVANCE
EQUITY AND VENTURE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT AND SUPPORT FOR
A FUNDING GAP TO ESTABLISH AND
MAINTAIN THE INCLUSIVE
ECOSYSTEMS. NEEDED TO CULTIVATE
PACKED UP AND PREPARE THEM TO
SCALE AND RAISE PRIVATE CAPITAL
. THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE WILL
ADDRESS THIS NEED TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE GROWTH IN TECH
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. BY PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR NONPROFIT
INCUBATORS AND ACCELERATORS. AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING FOR UNDERREPRESENTED
ENTREPRENEURS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION WE AFTER I VOTE ON
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS ANDREA
WHITE HERE'S MANAGING DIRECTOR
OF THE LONG BEACH ACCELERATOR.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE. THE LONG BEACH XCELERATED
OR IS THE FIVE OH ONE C. THREE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
ESTABLISHED AS A PUBLIC PRIVATE
UNIVERSITY PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH CAL STATE
LONG BEACH'S INSTITUTE FOR
INNOVATION AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT FIRM
PLANS DON'T MANAGEMENT. THE
MISSION OF THE LBA IS ALIGNED
WITH THE CITY OF LONG BEACH'S
BLUEPRINT FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WHICH PROVIDED
STATED VISION OF HOW LONG BEACH
WILL ADVANCE AS THE CITY OF
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DIVERSE WORKERS INVESTORS AND
ENTREPRENEURS. THE LPA PROVIDES
COHORT BASED INTENSIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE MENTORSHIP. INVESTOR
NETWORKING OPPORTUNITIES YOUR
SUPPORT AND ACCESS TO OUR
INNOVATION ECOSYSTEM AS WELL AS
STRATEGIC PARTNERS TO DIVERSE
TECHNOLOGY STARTUP FOUNDERS.
THIS COMBINATION OF RESOURCES
AND TRAINING RESULTS IN CREATING
COMPETITIVE STARTUP VASTLY
ACCELERATING GO TO MARKET. AND
EXPANSION. HE THINKS THAT'S
RIGHT. AND ULTIMATELY MAX
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND-
TRANSACTION LBA HAS BEEN FOCUSED
ON EQUITY IN THE EARLY STAGE
TECH ECOSYSTEM AT OUR FIRST
THREE COHORTS HAVE BEEN LED BY
OVER 50% FEMALE FOUNDERS AND
OVER 75% UNDERREPRESENTED
FOUNDERS OF ALL TRY. THIS
NETWORK IN OUR ECOSYSTEM MENTORS
. INVESTORS AND ADVISORS
SIMILARLY DIVERSE IN JUST THE
FIRST YEAR OF OPERATION THE
TWENTY ONE BEACH ACCELERATOR
GRADUATES HAVE RAISED OVER SEVEN
MILLION THE PRIVATE INVESTMENT
CAPITAL GENERATED OVER TWO AND A
HALF MILLION IN REVENUE AND HAVE
THREE ACQUISITION OFFERS. THE
AUDIENCE RESULT CAN AND SHOULD
BE A BLUEPRINT FOR OTHER
ACCELERATORS AROUND CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE PROVIDED YOUR F. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE WILL ENABLE
ACCELERATORS LIKE THE LPA IS
SCALE EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
JOB CREATION AND ATTRACTING
LEVERAGE PRIVATE INVESTMENT FOR
INNOVATIVE STARTUPS. AND
ULTIMATELY FOR CALIFORNIA
DREAMING IN THE HIGH TECH LEADER
IN THE WORLD. THANK YOU AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AT THREE
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MA'AM NOW LET'S MOVE TO THE
GALLERY TO SEE IF THERE ANY
WITNESSES WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT. ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF. THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE. THERE. BILL PARTICIPANTS
ARE QUEUING UP THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO THE
GALLERY TO SEE IF THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SAYING NO SUCH WITNESSES
LET'S MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE ONCE AGAIN MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE WE WILL
CONTINUE.
MR MODERATOR. SORRY ABOUT THAT I
WAS MUTED OUT TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS KILLING
UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SIR
LET'S BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
CHAMBER. STARTING WITH SENATOR
PAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANDERSON GONZALEZ I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND I DO I ALSO THINK STAFFORD
ANALYSIS BUT- I WOULD ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT. IT OUTLINES. THE
CHALLENGES FOR THE API
COMMUNITY- AS- I'M SURE THAT OUR
STAFF DID NOT THROW JOB IN
LOOKING AT THE DATA AND RESEARCH
AND AROUND THE- DISPARITIES IN-
IN TERMS OF EQUITY FUNDING BUT
THERE'S VERY LITTLE DATA ON THE
P. I. COMMUNITY OR THE NATIVE
HAWAIIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY- WHICH COURSES AND-
PARTICULARLY CITED- AND
ANALYSIS- AND I JUST MAKE NOTE
THAT- WE NEED TO DO BETTER JOB
OF GETTING DATA. ABOUT THAT AND
I ALSO KNOW MY GOOD FRIEND FROM-
LONG BEACH- SARGANT DOLLARS
REPRESENTS AND IS A GREAT
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE CAMBODIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. AND I WOULD
VENTURE TO SAY THAT- EVEN IN THE
ABSENCE OF DATA THAT THEIR
ACCESS TO- VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING IS PRIMED THAT
COMMITTEES PROBABLY- FAIRLY
COMPARE. PERHAPS TO SOME OF THE
OTHER GROUPS THAT ALSO HAVE LACK
OF ACCESS. SO I CERTAINLY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THE AUTHOR HAS-
TOUCHED ON THE ISSUES FOR THE
API COMEDIAN PERHAPS- YOU KNOW
MY NEW CLOTHES ALSO INDICATE-
THE FACT THAT THIS. FUND WOULD
ALSO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
PARTICULARLY SUB SEGMENTS OF THE
API COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY ON A
POINT. WONDERS AS WELL AS OTHER-
MORE DISADVANTAGE SUB SEGMENTS
OF THE API COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF
GETTING ACCESS TO. VENTURE
CAPITAL FOR. THEIR EFFORTS TO
ENGAGE IN THE TECH ECONOMY THANK
YOU. AND I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE TO
BUILD A PROTOTYPE THANK YOU
SENATOR CENTER BURGER. Q. OKAY.
I'M ALSO SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IN JUST A COUPLE
THINGS- WHY I BELIEVE THIS IS
REALLY NEEDED. UP AT STANFORD
RECENTLY DID A LATINO
ENTREPRENEURSHIP A STUDY THEY
SAID ACTUALLY GDP PRODUCED BY
THE TEENS IN THE U. S. WAS TWO
POINT ONE THREE TRILLION PART OF
THE G. PIECE OF INDIA ITALY OR
CANADA. BUT IS ALSO ANOTHER
STUDY WAS TRYING TO FIND A SPACE
HE SAID THAT IF WHAT YOU KNOW
ENTREPRENEURS WERE FUNDED AT THE
SAME RATE AS OVERALL
ENTREPRENEURS IT WOULD RESULT
IN. IN IT IN BILLIONS TO OUR
ECONOMY THAT WE'RE NOT REALIZING
NOW- ACTUALLY RAN A FUND WITH
TWO TEAMS ONE CLIMATE THAT ONE
WAS IN OUR CITY AND ETHNIC
ENTREPRENEURS AND- WE'VE SEEN
THAT INNER CITY NOTHING
CONTROVERSIAL ARE. UNDER FUNDED
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO- YOU KNOW
LACK ACCESS TO CAPITAL- AND
THAT'S NEGATIVE FOR OUR OVERALL
ECONOMY NOT EASY FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES SO BEFORE. TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR- ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SIR BAKER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS CALLING SIX SURVEYS. MY
FELLOW THERE. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
IN ONDO THANK YOU FOR THE BILL
OF. I DO HAVE A CONCERN I'M
GONNA SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I DO
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
SPECIFICITY ON HOW THE GRANTS
ARE GOING TO BE AWARDED TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS EQUITY AND
THAT THE GRANTS THEMSELVES GO
FOR THAT A VERY IMPORTANT
PURPOSE AND I'M ASSUMING AS IT
MOVES FORWARD THAT SOME OF THAT
DETAIL WILL BE INCLUDED AS YOU
WORK THROUGH IT BUT I JUST
NOTICED THAT OUR ANALYSIS IT HAS
THE SUPPORT BUT SOME CONCERNED
ON THE LACK OF DETAILS THAT ARE
GIVEN ON THE GRANT. PROGRAM
ITSELF WHICH IS BASICALLY THE
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF AT THE
COMMON DENOMINATOR THAT REALLY
GETS YOU WHERE YOU WANT TO GO
WITH THE GOAL OF THE BILL THE
JUST THAT COME IN AND AGAIN
THANKS FOR INTRODUCING IT IN R.
AS SHE WORKS THROUGH IT ALL JUST
KEEP TOUCH WITH IT AND YOU MIGHT
DIAL BACK WITH ME IF YOU CAN
ANSWER SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS
AS IT MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SURVEYS I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES UP FELLOW SURGEONS
ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND I
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR SENATOR
PAD ON- OUR API COMMUNITY NEED
TO BE VERY EXPLICIT HAVING A
CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY MY BACKYARD
ENSURING THAT THEY'RE ALSO
RECEIVING FUNDING FUNDING AT
PAR- INTO A SENATOR BATES
POINTS- WE ARE CURRENTLY I HAVE
A COMPANION BILL LOOKING AT
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS- A
COMPANION BUDGET ASK. EXCUSE ME
pJUST FOCUSED ON THIS AND I AGREE
THERE NEEDS TO BE TRANSPARENCY
IN DATA TO ENSURE THAT THES
DOLLARS ARE ACTUALLY GETTING TO
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF-
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES SO
WITH THAT WHEN I THINK MY
WITNESSES AND I CERTAINLY ASK
FOR YOUR EYEBALLS AND SP THREE
TO THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE THANK
YOU SENATOR DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE OKAY. THE ORIGINAL OUT OF
THE BILL'S. BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. MOST IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON A PER. BOTTOMS TO
READ PLEASE GO THE ROLL. SENATE-
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE DO YOU PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RALPH KLEIN ROSS
I MELINDA'S ARCHULETA HI.
MARSHALL WHAT I BEAT ALL RIGHT
BEATS I BACKER BY BECKER I DON
HI DON I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I. HER
TADO JONES BY JONES I. LEIVA.
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
ASSURE BOGUS. UNTIL ABOUT I. P.
N. HI CAN I. BILL HAS ELEVEN
VOTES WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. PEN YOU HAVE ONE
BILL TODAY SENATE BILL TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU. MR
CHAIR US SENATORS I PRESENT TO
YOU SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN A MEASURE THAT SEEKS TO
ADDRESS UNMET DEMAND INTO
LABORATORY FEELS THAT NOT
CURRENTLY RECOGNIZED IN STATE
LAW. GENETICISTS AND
REPRODUCTIVE BIOLOGISTS. ARE NOT
CURRENTLY LICENSED REGULATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH OFTEN FORCING HER TO.
CALIFORNIANS ARE WHO ARE
SEEKING- ASSISTED REPRODUCTIVE
THERAPY LAB SERVICES TO PERHAPS
SEEK THEM OUT OF STATE. BECAUSE
OF THIS UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
CALIFORNIA FARM PUBLIC HEALTH IS
ABLE TO CREATE NEW LICENSE
CATEGORIES WHEN THEY DEEM THAT A
NEW CATEGORIES NECESSARY
HOWEVER. THE DEPARTMENT CAN ONLY
APPLY FEES FOR LICENSES RENEWALS
OF CLINICAL LABORATORY
SCIENTISTS AND TRAINEES IN THESE
FIELDS. OUR DEPARTMENT CANNOT
APPLY LICENSURE FEES FOR
LABORATORY DIRECTORS FOR
SPECIALTIES NOT PRESCRIBED IN
STATUTE THAT MEANS THEY CANNOT
ISSUE LICENSES DIRECTORS IN
THESE FIELDS. S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN WOULD SIMPLY ADD
LABORATORY GENETICISTS AND
REPRODUCTIVE BIOLOGISTS TO STATE
LAW THIS WILL ALLOW C. PH TO
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE IN THESE
AREAS AND ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT
TO COLLECT THE FEES ASSISTING
THE LICENSING OVERSIGHT PROGRAM.
LICENSURE OF DIRECTORS IN THESE
FIELDS ALSO REDUCE OUR
DEPENDENCY ON OUT OF STATE
SERVICES AND WORK SPANNED A
NUMBER LABORATORY PERSONNEL ABLE
TO PERFORM THIS WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO WANT TO.
THANK THE COMMITTEE- ANALYSIS
AND NOTE THE COMMENT ABOUT
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN
FACT OF MY OFFICE TO MAKE
CONTACT WITH THE REPRESENTATIVES
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH THEM. SHOULD
THE COMMITTEE DECIDED TO- FAST
MOVE THIS BILL. WITH ME I HAVE
FOR MY WITNESSES- MR ROBERT
THOMAS BRANCH CHIEF AND- MISS
WELKE. YEAH AND ARE THE
CALIFORNIA THE PUBLIC LAB FIELD
SERVICES ARE THEY ARE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE EXPECT WE ASK FOR A
NIGHT OUT. THANK YOU SELLER
LEADS- HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES.
IN THE GALLERY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES. WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH WITNESSES WHO ARE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SENATE
BILL TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR- SP TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND ANYBODY ONE ONE
WILL BE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS
KILLING UP- BUT I THINK WE JUST
GOT ONE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
SHOULD BE WITH US MOMENTARILY
THERE WITH THE OPERATOR. ANYBODY
ELSE A TEST FLIGHT SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND WE WERE LYING NINETEEN YOUR
OPEN. THANK YOU ARE YOU MUTED.
YEAH THANK YOU. THE MOBILE
NUMBER BOROUGH I'M DEPRESSED NOT
THAT I THEY ARE BECAUSE OF THE
REDUCTION BIOLOGIST AND I LIKE
OF SUPPORT THE BILLS SB TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU SIR
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. NOBODY
ELSE HAS QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FIRST MOVING TO THE
GALLERY WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT. ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN WE WILL CONTINUE
WITH THEM. BECAUSE BY AN
OPPOSITION TO TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
I SEE NO MICROPHONES UP. SO IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
THEIR PLAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ESPECIALLY AFTER A NIGHT
OUT THANK YOU. OKAY BILL MOVED
BY SENATOR NEWMAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS FOR YOUR FOR THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. NFL TWELVE SIXTY
SEVENTY POSSUM REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RALPH BY RALPH I MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D BE ALL
RIGHT BEATS I BACKER ALL RIGHT
BACKER I DON. DOT I EXAMINE X.
MEN I HER TADO FURTADO I JONES.
JONES I. LEIVA MEN ARE MEN I
NEWMAN. FOR NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN I SHOW A VOGUE EDITOR
VOGUE IPN NIGHT N. I. BILL HAS
TWELVE VOTES WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. CENTER OF
SHOWBOAT YOUR ONE BILL TODAY
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE.
YOU'RE FREE TO- PRESENT FROM
YOUR DESK RECEIVE ONE READING.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE WILL
FULLY INTEGRATE ALL UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES INTO THE CALL BEFORE
YOU DIG LAW BY ADDING CALTRANS
AS A UTILITY OPERATOR UNDER THE
STATE'S TWO REGIONAL SUB SERVICE
UTILITY NOTIFICATION CENTERS AND
BY ADDING NON PRESSURIZED SEWER
LINES AND STORM DRAINS TO THE
DEFINITION OF. SUB SERVICE
INSTALLATION CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES AN INDIVIDUAL OR ENTITY
PLANNING TO PERFORM AN
EXCAVATION TO INFORM ONE OF TWO
REGIONAL NOTIFICATION CENTERS SO
OPERATORS OF ANY UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES IN THAT AREA CAN MARK
THEIR FACILITIES. THE LAW IS
INTENDED TO PREVENT EXCAVATORS
FROM DAMAGING UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES ONCE IN THIS COMPUTER
CONTACTS A REGIONAL NOTIFICATION
CENTER CALLED LOCALLY REFERRED
TO AS EIGHT ELEVEN. OR EIGHT ONE
ONE ONE OR MORE UTILITY
OPERATORS MARK THE LOCATION OF
THEIR UNDERGROUND FACILITIES
WITH PAINT FLAGS OR BY OTHER
MEANS. IT IS THEN THE ESCALATORS
RESPONSIBILITY TO DETERMINE THE
EXACT LOCATION OF THE FACILITIES
AND AVOID DAMAGING THEM. EIGHT
TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
FEDERAL REPORT PRODUCED BY
PIPELINE AND HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION GAVE
CALIFORNIA A LOWER GRADE BECAUSE
THE TWO NOTIFICATION CENTERS DO
NOT CURRENTLY INCLUDE CALTRANS.
WHO OPERATE RELATIVELY FEW SUB
SERVICE INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN
THE ADJACENT TO ITS RIGHT OF
WAYS. THE REPORT ALSO CITED THE
EXCLUSION OF NON PRESSURIZED
SEWER LINES OR STORM DRAINS AS
REASONS FOR THE LOWER
ASSESSMENT. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
REMEDY BOTH OF THOSE
DEFICIENCIES ADDITIONALLY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMON GROUND
ALLIANCE A STATE CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO EXCAVATION SAFETY CONSISTING
OF UTILITIES YOU DON'T UTILITY
LOCATING COMPANIES AND
EXCAVATORS IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
ADDITIONAL SHORTCOMINGS WITH
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHT ONE ONE LAW.
AND THOSE ARE THE FUNCTIONAL AND
CLARIFYING ISSUES ADDRESSED IN
THIS BILL. I ALSO WANTED TO KNOW
THAT BECAUSE OF THE QUICK MOVING
NATURE OF THIS BILL AND THE LAST
MINUTE OPPOSITION WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES CONCERNS. IN THIS
COMMITTEE. HOWEVER I AM
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM
MOVING FORWARD AND HAVE A
MEETING SCHEDULED WITH THEM THIS
WEEK. WEDNESDAY ACTUALLY TO WORK
OUT THE ISSUES JOINING ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND HELP TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
IS TODD BLOOM STEIN. ON BEHALF
OF THE SPONSOR THE UNDERGROUND
SERVICE ALERT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE ALERT. THANK YOU
SENATOR SIR IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN BURST HOT BALLOON SIGN
ON BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR THE
UNDERGROUND SERVICE ALERT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CALMLY
CALLED DIGGER ALERT- I ALSO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE AMENDS THE CALL BEFORE YOU
DIG LAW IT IS A FREE SERVICE FOR
ANY PERSON OR COMPANY PLANNING
TO DIG INTO THE GROUND. THE
SERVICE REQUIRES MOST UTILITIES
TO LOCATE AND MARK THEIR
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES IN ORDER
FOR THE PERSON OR COMPANY
EXCAVATING TO DO SO SAFELY
AROUND POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES DILLARD
REPORTS A SUCCESS RATE OF 99% IN
AVOIDING UNDERGROUND UTILITIES
FOR THOSE THAT USE THE LAW. SB
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE ORIGINATED
FROM AN INDUSTRY WORKING GROUP
CALLED CARGA THE CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL COMMON GROUND ALLIANCE
CARGO CONSISTS OF UTILITY
COMPANIES EXCAVATORS AND
COMPANIES THAT LOCATE AND MARK
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE IS PRIMARILY
A TECHNICAL BILL DEVELOPED BY
CORGAN'S INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES. THE BILL DOES
EXPAND THE SERVICE TO GRAVITY
DRIVEN SEWER LINES AND OF OTHER
SIMILAR INFRASTRUCTURE. WE
UNDERSTAND THE OPPONENTS ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE COST AND
ABILITY TO ACCURATELY LOCATE
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE
SCHEDULED TO MEET AS THE AUTHOR
SAID I WITH THE OPPONENTS AND
WORK THROUGH THOSE ISSUES- THIS
WEEK. IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT
OVER THE LAST DECADE NOTABLY
ASSEMBLYMEN LEVINS AT ELEVEN
SIXTY SIX WHICH WAS SIGNED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN REDUCES SOME OF
THE WORKLOAD ON UTILITY
OPERATORS BY TRANSITIONING TO
PURELY ELECTRONIC REPORTING-
THIS CHANGE MIGHT BE BENEFICIAL
TO THOSE CONCERNED ABOUT COST
AND WORKLOAD ISSUES. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SIR. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE. SEE NO WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ERVAS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT. ANY
SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK YOU. BY
TWO EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THIRTY
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. EMISSION SHARE
WE WERE LIKE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MAC CRIMMINS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR MODERATOR NEXT
PLEASE. NOW WE WILL GO LIVE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS JANE GOING GATE I'M FROM
UNDERGROUND SERVICE ALERT OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA NEVADA
COMMONLY KNOWN ISSUE WITH THE
NORTH EIGHT ONE ONE EIGHT ONE
ONE CONTACT CENTER THAT ACTS
LIKE DISPATCH. FOR THIRTEEN
HUNDRED UTILITY OPERATORS THE
NORTHERN AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
STRONGLY- WE HEAR MANY TIMES
FROM EXCAVATORS ABOUT YOU WERE
LINES THAT ARE DAMAGED AS WELL
AS FACILITIES OWNED BY CALTRANS.
AND WHILE THE BILL IS PRIMARILY
TECHNICAL IN NATURE WITH A
NUMBER OF- SMALL- ENHANCEMENTS
THAT WILL HELP FACILITATE BETTER
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN ACTIVATOR
AND UTILITY OPERATORS THE-
REQUIREMENT TO ADD CALTRANS AND
THE OPERATORS OF NON PRESSURIZED
SEWER AND DRAIN LINE INTO THE
FOLD IS CRITICAL TO SUCCESS OUR
UNDERGROUND UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE. IS UNDER MORE
PRESSURE THAN EVER BEFORE WITH
THE- COBIZ PAVING THE WAY FOR
WORK AT HOME ALL THAT HAPPENED
EXACTLY ONLY IF THE UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE IS UP AND WORKING
PROPERLY. ALL THE THINGS WE TAKE
FOR GRANTED THAT DEFINE US AS A
FIRST WORLD COUNTRY COMPARED TO
THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES ARE ALL
RELATED TO INFRASTRUCTURE SO
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO PROTECT
IT YOU CAN HAVE CATASTROPHIC
EFFECTS INCLUDING UP TO DEATH
WHEN- WHEN UTILITY LIKE COULD BE
DAMAGED SO. I REQUEST YOUR I.
BOATS AND I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. AND AS A REMINDER PRESS
ZERO TWO TESTED. IN SUPPORT. NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO THIS
MEASURE. FIRST LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION I SEE
ONE SIR PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AT YOUR ORGANIZATION AND-
RECEIVE PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MY DEALER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
SANITATION AGENCIES ALL OF THE
MAJOR WASTEWATER AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA. AS MENTIONED KASA
DOES HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL
HOWEVER WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR JOE BOTH STAFF
AND THE SPONSOR AS- THE SENATOR
MENTIONED AND WE BELIEVE WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT. LASTLY MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD LIKE TO COMPLIMENT YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT EXCELLENT ANALYSIS ON
THE BILL THIS IS SOMEWHAT
COMPLICATED SUBJECT IT WAS A
VERY GOOD ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
THE BEST IN THE BUSINESS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROMPT
ANY SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH THEM IT. PLEASE
PRESS STAR ONE PROBABLY ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP SHARE. OKAY LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER ALEX
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS. I
SEE- I SEE DOCTOR PENN CENTER
PAN PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
AND- SARAH SHOW BY APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
I APPRECIATE THE LATE
OPPOSITION- THAT YOU'LL BE
TALKING TO THEM AND I APPRECIATE
THEIR TESTIMONY TO BE WORKING
WITH YOU- AND I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE WHY IT'S GONNA BE MORE
EXPENSIVE THE MARK BUT YOU KNOW
I'M NOT EXPERT ON THAT THEY THEY
ARE SO I'M SURE YOU'LL WORK IT
OUT WITH THEM SO WITH THAT-
AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR BEING SO
FORWARD AND MOVE THE BILL.
SEARCH BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. ACTUALLY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THIS BILL WILL INCREASE
THE SAFETY OF EXCAVATORS WHO
NEED TO DIG IN AREAS THAT
CONTAIN SUB SERVICE
INSTALLATIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPO. THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAN THE MOTION. IS TO PASS
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. MADAM
STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE DO YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE ROTH HI ROSS I MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D BE ALL
RIGHT B. I. BACKER. HI BECKER I
DON I DON I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I.
HER TADO. FURTADO I'D JONES. BY
JOHN FIVE LLEVA MAIN MAIN HI
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN I UNTIL
A BOGEY. SEARCHABLE SHOW ABOUT A
TERRIBLE GUY PNI CAN I. THE BILL
HAS TWELVE BOOKS AND THE BILL IS
OUT. MINISTER OF DIRECTOR LET'S
GO BACK AND CALL THE ROLL ON
THOSE BILLS THAT WERE HELD OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS MEMBERS
PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONE ON
YOUR VOTE IS AUDIBLE IN CAN BE
RECORDED- PROCREATE. AND WE'LL
START WITH THAT CONSENT FILE
WHICH TODAY INCLUDES FILE ITEMS
FIVE SB ELEVEN TWENTY AND FILING
AND EAT AS B. FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE. THE CURRENT VOTE ON THE
CONSENT FOLLIS TEND TO ZERO
MELINDA'S. DAUGHTER I DON I HER
TADO I HEARD TOMORROW HI LISA.
VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM ONE SP TEN SIXTY
FOUR CURRENT VOTE TEN TO ZERO
MELINDA'S. DAUGHTER I THOUGHT I
HEARD TOMORROW HI HER TADO HI
LISA. LOTUS TWELVE ZERO BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEMS Q. SP TEN
SEVENTY FIVE CURRENT VOTE NINE
TWO ZERO MELINDA'S. BACKER
BACKER I'D DIED HI DONNA HI HER
TADO I FURTADO HI LISA. LOTUS
TWELVE ZERO BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
THREE F. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR
CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. BACKER HI BACKER HI
HER TADO FIND HER TADO I BELIEVE
THAT. LOTUS TWELVE ZERO BILL AS
A. THE FINAL ITEM FOR S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE CURRENT
VOTE ELEVEN TWO ZERO MELINDA'S.
HER TADO I FOR TARO HI LISA.
LOTUS TWELVE ZERO BILLS OUT. BY
LATER SIX SB TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO.
MELINDA'S. LEAVE A- PHOTOS
TWELVE ZERO BILLS OF.
WELL THIS CONCLUDES THE HEARING
THANK YOU TO ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT O US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS OF POSSIBLE.
THANKS TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION AS I
INDICATED WE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IS
ADJOURNED.